[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من طهران التي التقى فيها المدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
مسؤولين في هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
حول البرنامج النووي الايراني
وهذه الصور تاتينا من العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس حيث تتفاعل من جديد قضيه القاعده
الانتخابيه لاسيما على ضوء اتفاق بين
المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب
ومن رام الله هذه الصور تصلنا ايضا في وقت
يستمر فيه الاحتقان في الضفه الغربيه جراء
عمليات قوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين رغم
الادانات الدوليه
اختراق في طهران في ختام زياره جروسي
ايران توافق على اعاده تشغيل كاميرات
مراقبه وزياده عمليات التفتيش الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ترحب بضمانات طهران
تمهيدا لاجتماع يحدد وسائل تنفيذ
التفاهمات
ورئيسي يدعو الوكلاء الى النيء بالنفس عن
اي ضغوط سياسيه
[موسيقى]
تونس بين تصعيد وتحذير وترقب احتجاجات
نقابيه رافضه لاستهداف الحريات الامين
العام للاتحاد الشغل يحذر من خطاب ترهيب
وتصفيه حسابات ومع استمرار موجه
الاعتقالات جمعيه القضاه التونسيين تقول
ان القضاه يتعرضون لضغوط غير مسبوقه
وتطالب الرئيس بالكف عن الاجراءات
الانتقاميه ضدهم
قبل جلسه مرتقبه للبرلمان الليبي لاعتماد
تعديل دستوري والشروع في وضع قوانين
انتخابيه رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه يطالب
باخضاع اي تعديل للاستفتاء الشعبي ويقول
ان حل الازمه السياسيه يكون بدستور توافقي
ويؤكد رفضه لعوده الحكم العسكري مجددا
معارك السيطره على باخموت المحاصره تحتدم
قائد العمليات الخاصه بالجيش الاوكراني
يتفقد جنوده في المدينه ويؤكد ان القوات
تعمل في ظروف شديده صعوبه لوقت الهجمات
الروسيه ووزير الدفاع الروسيه تجول في
محور جنوب دونتس ويشدد على تنظيم عمل
قواته ويبحث امدادها بمزيد من الذخائر
والاسلحه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان رئيس حكومه الوحدات
الوطنيه في ليبيا عبد الحميد الدبيبه ان
اي قاعده دستوريه يجب ان تطرح الاستفتاء
شعبي وان عوده الحكم العسكري لليبيا غير
مقبوله ياتي ذلك بعد موافقه المجلس الاعلى
للدوله على تعديل دستوري يمهد لاجراء
انتخابات في البلاد بالاتفاق مع مجلس
النواب لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم الى اين يتجه مسار الازمه الليبيه
26% وقعوا تفاهما على اجراء الانتخابات
وقال 68% ان الازمه تتجه الى مزيد من
الانقسام السياسي بينما قال سته في المئه
فقط انها تتجه لتوافق على مبادره مبعوث
الاممي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد يوم من الاعلان عن مناورات امريكيه
كوريه جنوبيه اشار الجاري كوريا الشماليه
تعتبرها تهديدا عسكريا
وتمهيدا لغزوها
[موسيقى]
اصدرت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بيانا مشتركا مع هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه في ختام زياره مدير العام
للوكاله رافائيل جروسي الى طهران جاء في
البيان ان ايران مستعده لمواصله التعاون
مع الوكاله بشان ثلاثه مواقع قالت الوكاله
انها غير معلنه وعثرت فيها على اثار
لليورانيوم كما ابدى تيران استعدادها
لتقديم مزيد من المعلومات بشانها والوصول
اليها من اجل معالجه قضايا الضمانات
المتبقيه واضاف البيان ان ايران ستسمح
للوكاله الدوليه عند الحاجه بالقيام بمزيد
من انشطه التحقق والاشراف في المنشات
النوويه على ان يتم الاتفاق على طريقه ذلك
خلال اجتماع تقني سيعقد في طهران قريبا
هذا وقال مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفع الجروسي ان البيان المشترك مع
ايران نتيجه ملموسه وصلبه لمحادثات
الطرفين واضاف ان بعض اجهزه المراقبه في
ايران سيجري تشغيلها قريبا واوضح ان هناك
تحسنا ملحوظا في الحوار مع الجانب
الايراني واضاف جروسي ان الوكاله ستجري
تحقيقات باسرع ما يمكن بشان الاثار
النوويه في مواقع غير معلن عنها في ايران
تقييم الوكاله انه في الوقت الحالي لم
نحصل من ايران على الالتزام الذي نسعى
اليه ولد ايران تقييمه الخاص نحاول تحقيق
تقارب فيما يتعلق بما يسمى القضايا
العالقه بالنسبه لنا كانت العمليه طويله
اكثر مما يجب واعتقد ان تقدما تحقق في
حوار مع الايرانيين اعتقد انه تم الاستماع
الي وسنرى نتائج كما تعرفون في الاشهر
الماضيه كان هناك تقليص لبعض عمليه
التفتيش فيما يتعلق بالكاميرات والمتابعه
الالكترونيه
كانت بعضها لا تعمل وقد اتفقنا انها ستعمل
من جديد وسنتفق على طرق تطبيق هذا
وفي طهران نقل مراسل الجزيره عن الرئاسه
الايرانيه قولها ان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي ابلغ مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
بان لدى ايران اراده قويه وحسنانيه
للتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
كما قال رئيسي ان طهران تامل من وكاله
الطاقه الذريه التعامل بمهنيه وعدم التاثر
بقوه سياسيه تسعى لاهداف خاصه مشيرا الى
ان امريكا والكيان الصهيوني يستغلان ملف
ايران النووي ذريعه لممارسه الضغوط على
الشعب الايراني حصل تعبيره
من جهه يا قله الخارجيه الايرانيه ان وزير
الخارجيه حسين امير عبد اللهيان والمدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اكد
على تعزيز التعاملات المتفق عليها بين
الطرفين واضافت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان
الوزير اكد ليجروسي وجود اراده جديه لدى
طهران لحل القضايا التقنيه في اطار
الضمانات مع الوكاله في اسرع وقت
يستفق اجتماع محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه فيحل في طهرا مدير الوكاله
اختار ان يلتقي مسؤول البرنامج النووي
الايراني وهو محمل بتساؤلات عن منشا
جزيئات اليورانيوم على التخسيب ويبحث عن
اجابات لما تبقى من ملفات عالقه
اثبتت ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم
المخصب لا يتجاوز نسبه 60% لهذا السبب ليس
هناك ما يستدعي التركيز على هذه النقاط
ويمكن القول انها سويت نوعا ما فيما يخص
المواقع الثلاثه وصلنا مع السيد بروسي الى
اطار عمل مشترك خلال زياره السابقه الى
فيينا وسنواصل العمل في الاطار نفسه
لا يرفع جروسي منسوب التفاؤل ولا يريد ان
يكون متشائما في التعاون مع ايران فهو
يريد الابقاء على صفحه التعاون مفتوحه
بعيدا عن تجاذبات السياسه كما يقول
يجب ان يكون لدينا محادثات جاده وعميقه مع
ايران فهي هدف زيارتي ما زال العمل جاريا
وستستمر اللقاءات مع رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايراني وبقيه المسؤولين وفي
النهايه سنكون قادرين على الحكم بشان
مستوى الرضا من هذه الزياره
حديث تقني بامتياز بين طهران والوكاله
بشان برنامج ايران النووي لم تعد تقيده
شروط الاتفاق النووي بعد انسحاب واشنطن
منه فازداد عدد اجهزه الطرد المركزي
وانواعها تقول الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان سقف انتاج اليورانيوم تنوع في
ايران منذ 2019
وتجاوز مخزونه ما هو منصوص عليه في
الاتفاق بعشره اضعاف ولا تزال تبحث عن
اجابات عن من شيء اثار لليورانيوم في
مواقع لم يعلن عنها للمفتشين في وقت سابق
قضايا ومستجدات يدخل عليها البرنامج
النووي الايراني فترتفع نبره التهديدات
القادمه من الخارج لاستهداف المنشات
النوويه فيلوح القاده العسكريون في ايران
بان اي تحرك سيقابل برد من دون
شكال التهديدات الاسرائيليه عباره عن
اعلاميه والمسؤولون العسكريون الايرانيون
اع انه اذا شنت اي حرب على ايران فستكون
حربا شامره تتجاوز الخدود الايرانيه
اذا تحت وتيره التصعيد مع ايران على خلفيه
برنامجها النوم تسعى طهران الى تهدئه
الاجواء بفتح مسار تفاوضي مع وكاله الطاقه
الذريه وهناك من يرى في ذلك خطوه لوقف اي
تحرك اوروبي ضدها في اجتماع محافظ الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ياتي جروسي الى
طهران فهذا جزء من عمله للابقاء على
التواصل مع ايران كما يقول وهناك من يرى
انه لا يعني بالضروره حل الملفات العالقه
او خفض مستوى التوتر للقائم مع الغرب على
خلفيه البرنامج النووي حتى لو تحدث كثيرون
عن ايجابيات التواصل بين ايران والوكاله
طهران
معنى من طهران مصطفى خورشيد جشم استاذ
الاعلام والسياسه في جامعه فارس ومن لندن
ينضم الينا بيتر جان كينز السفير
البريطانيه السابق لدى الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه نبدا معك سيد مصطفى من
طهران ما سر هذه المرونه هذه الليونه من
الجانب الايراني مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه امر لم يكن متوقعا قبل
الزياره
كما تعرفون ان ايران كانت
ملتزمه بالضمانات واتفاق الضمانات الخاصه
بهذا الامر لكن لسوء الوكاله الدوليه
والغرب كانوا يطالبون ايران بالتزامي
باتفاق نوويه جديد ضمنه البروتوكول
الاضافي وحتى لو ان
الولايات المتحده والاوروبيونه لما يعطوا
ايران اي شيء بالمقابل مقابله هذا الاتفاق
بالتالي كان هنالك مطالب لايران من
الالتزام بهذه
الضمانات بشكل احادي الجانب لكن كما قال
اليوم مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ولحسن الحظ فان الوكاله الدوليه قد قبلت
بتقييد المطالب التي المطلوبه من ايران
اتفاق الضمانات وايضا التوقف عن التقدم
بايقاف بطلبات اضافيه قضايا الاختلاف بين
الطرفين هي تتعلق باتفاق الضمانات لكن
لسوء الحظ كلما قامت ايران بتقديم المزيد
من المعلومات للوكاله كلما قامت الوكاله
بزياده مطالبها الى ايران حتى بما يتجاوز
التزاماته الخاص بالضمان ولكن الموضوع
يعني الذي اطرحه السيد مصطفى سيد مصطفى
الموضوع الموضوع الذي اطرحه مثلا
المواقع الثلاثه هذه المواقع الثلاثه كانت
ايران ترفض مطلقا ان تفصح عنها ان تتحدث
عنها وتعتبر ان الوكاله تستند الى معلومات
استخباراتيه تحديدا من اسرائيل كما كانت
تقول ايران الان ايران لا مشكله لديها في
ان تقدم معلومات ستتعاون مع الوكاله بشان
هذه المواقع الثلاثه وايضا ستعود
كاميرات مراقبه الى مواقع اخرى يعني هذا
الامر كيف تم التوصل اليه ولماذا كانت
ايران ايجابيه الى هذا المستوى
مع الوكاله خلال حول هذه المواقع الثلاثه
كانت في خاصه في شهرزاد في اصفهان وقد كان
هنالك الكثير من الاسئله حول ذلك الموقع
لكن ما كانوا يطالبونه كان يتجاوز
المعلومات الايرانيه ايران وفرت للوكاله
كل ما لديها من المعلومات وكل ما لديها من
البيانات خلال شهر مارس الماضي عندما كان
قروسيا حاضرا في طهران وايران قامت بتقديم
كل المعلومات التي متوفره لديها لكن للاسف
هم طلبوا المزيد وكان هذا ان هي نقطه
الخلاف الان الطرفاني اتفقا مع بعضهم
البعض من اجل وضع قيود على كل شيء وتحديده
باتفاق الضمانات من جهه اخرى هذا قد يكون
اتفاق لانه ربما قد يكون هنالك زياده
لعمليات التفتيش والم وايضا من قبل
الوكاله لكن تحت وضمن اتفاق ضمانات وليس
تحت البروتوكول الاضافي او او شروط
الاتفاقيات هذان امران مختلفان لان عمليات
التفتيش حسب البروتوكول الاضافي تسمح
بزيارات مفاجئه لكن هذه الزيارات وعمليات
التحقيق عمليات التفتيش ستكون مخطط له
بالتالي تتماشى مع اتفاقيات الضمانات
[موسيقى]
هل كنت تتوقع هذه الايجابيه من طهران في
هذا الاجتماع
انا سعيد جدا لسماعي الاستاذ
يقول ان هذا الامر متماشي مع التزاماتي
ايران
اتفاق اتفاقيه
الحد من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه من اجل
التحقق من المواد التي يبدو وكانها موجوده
في المواقع الثلاثه التي كانت هي محور قلق
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الدوليه لاكثر من
عام بالتالي هذا هذه نتيجه ايجابيه للغايه
لا استطيع الجزم اذا ما كنت اتوقع هذا
الامر ام لا لكنني على على ان
نفرح بهذه النتيجه
وان ايران قامت بشكل طوعي بتحسين
الياتي المراقبه والتفتيش للوكاله في
المواقع لا نعرف اي المواقع تحديدا في هذه
المرحله لكن اي شيء هم مستعدين لتقديمه هو
امر مهم ومرحب به هل تعتقد بيتر ان ايران
قطعت الطريق على
دول اوروبيه في مجلس محافظي الوكاله في
الاجتماع المقبل والذي والتي كان ربما
تريد ان تضغط على ايران او تحيل هذا الملف
من جديد الى مجلس الامن هل قطعت ايران
الطريق على هذه المحاولات من خلال تلك
الايجابيه التي ادتها
هو انه كان هنالك احتماليه ضئيله لقيام
الاوروبينا والولايات المتحده باحاله
ايران الى مجلس الامن
الى مجلس الحكام
للوكاله اعتقد انه كان هنالك امكانيه
لربما لقرارات اضافيه
اجتماعهم الاخير الذي دعوا لعقده حول
ايران والذي طالب ايران بطاقه التعاون حول
هذه المواقع الثلاثه ارغب بالتفكير ان ما
خرج من زياره المدير مدير الوكاله سيكون
كافيا لعكس هذه الاحتماليه لكن ليس لدي اي
طريقه ممكنه للتاكد من هذا الامر
سفير البريطاني السابق لدى الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه من لندن شكرا جزيلا
لك وشكرا لمصطفى
في جامعه فارس كان معنا من طهران
اعلن وزير الداخليه الايرانيه احمد وحيد
في بيان له انه خلال تحقيقات الميدانيه
بشان حالات التسمم في مدارس الفتيات في
ايران تم العثور على ما وصفه بالعينات
المثيره للشبهه وقال ان هذه العينات ارسلت
الى مختبرات متخصصه وسوف يتم الاعلان عن
نتائج التحاليل عبر وزاره الصحه واضاف
وزير الداخليه انه تم تسجيل حالات تسمم
اثنتين وخمسين مدرسه على الاقل حتى اليوم
وتشهد ايران سلسله احداث تسمم في مدارس
الفتيات منذ نهايه نوفمبر تشرين الثاني
الماضي يعتقد انها ناجمه عن غاز
النيتروجين كان اخرها تسجيل حالات تسمم
اليوم في ست محافظات وفق وكاله انباء فارس
وكان الرئيس الايراني قد قال ان حالات
التسمم هي ملف امني ياتي في اطار الحرب
الاعلاميه والنفسيه التي يشنها العدو ضد
ايران
حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
نظمنا الاتحاد والعامه التونسي للشغل
تجمعا عمليا واسعا بالعاصمه تونس في اطار
سلسله تحركاته الاحتجاجيه الاسبوعيه واكد
الامين العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبي
ان الاتحاد لن يقبل بقمع الحريات في
البلاد مهما كانت النتيجه وانه يرفض ترهيب
الناس ودعا الى وحده القوه الديمقراطيه في
تونس كما قال الطبوب ان الاتحاد يتعرض
للهجوم بسبب تقديمه مبادره لحل الازمه
السياسيه
مستحضرا رمزيه المكان وتاريخه من مقره
الرئيسي بالعاصمه التونسيه اراد الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل لهذا التحرك ان يكون
الاكبر والاكثر حشدا جماهيريا
امتدت تحركات الاتحاد الى جميع الولايات
التونسيه بعد تصاعد عوامل تاجيج الخلاف
بينه وبين السلطه فبعد الملاحقات القضائيه
لعدد من اعضائها ترى المنظمه النقابيه ان
استهدافها بلغ حد طرد ضيوفها من النقابيين
الدوليين ومنع التضامن معها
وعمال العالم متحدين ضد القرى وضد الظلم
وضد ضرب الحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وضد الضرب الحق النقابي وحق الاضراب كلف
ذلك ما كلفنا
اطراف سياسيه ومدنيه من مشارب مختلفه ساند
التحرك الاتحاد الذي عبر بدوره عن تضامنه
مع جميع السياسيين والناشطين المعتقلين
مشددا على تمسكه بدوره الوطني بعيدا عن
الاستفافات السياسيه
تؤكد رسائل هذا التحرك العمالي الاتحاد
الشغل ان الملفات الاجتماعيه لم تعد
الشاغله الوحيد للمنظمه النقابيه فصاع
اليوم من اجل الوجود في ظل ما يصفه
الاتحاد باستهداف العمل النقابي وسعي
السلطه الى ضرب المؤسسه العماليه
الرئيس قيس سعيد استبق تحركات اتحاد الشغل
برسائل واضحه ومباشره رفض من خلالها
مشاركه اطراف اجنبيه في الاحتجاجات
النقابيه واعتبر من جهه اخرى ان تحركات
نقابات التعليم
ضمن خانه الحسابات السياسيه هناك من يريد
ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
خلافات السلطه مع اتحاد الشغل ومشهد
الشارع المتمل ليست سوى احد اوجه المشهد
المتوتر في تونس فعلى وقع الملاحقات
القضائيه ايضا تحتد الازمه بين السلطه
والمعارضه السياسيه بعد اعتقال سياسيين
وناشطين بارزين من معارض سعيد ليضرب
الشارع ايضا موعدا مع تحرك احتجاجي اخر
تصر جبهه الانقاذ على تنفيذه رغم رفض
السلطات ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره تونس
في هذه الاثناء قالت جمعيه القضاه
التونسيين ان تصريحات الرئيس السعي اتجاه
القضاه تشكل خطوره وتدخلا مباشرا في
التحقيقات ودعت الجمعيه في بيان الرئيس
والسلطه التنفيذيه الى الكف عن الاجراءات
الانتقاميه ضد القضاه لافته الى وجود ضغوط
كبيره وغير مسبوقه يتعرض لها القضاه على
اثر الاعتقالات الاخيره وكان الرئيس قيس
سعيد قد صرح بانه حان وقت محاسبه من سماهم
المتامرين على امن الدوله واضاف ان القضاه
او على القضاه المساهمه في معركه التحرير
الوطني على حد تعبيره
من تونس معنا احمد الهمامي المتحدث باسم
تحالف احرار ومن تونس ايضا طريق السعيده
الصحفيه بجريده الشعب التابعه للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل ابدا معك السيد احمد
العمامي هو اتحاد الشغل التونسي اليوم
يعني اصبح موقفه واضحا ضد قرارات وسياسات
الرئيس قيس السعيد
ويحرك الشارع في هذا الاتجاه دفاعا عن
الحريات النقابيه من بقي للرئيس قيس سعيد
اذا اضفنا ايضا بيان
القضاه الذي صدر اليوم
شكرا لك تحياتي لك ولكل متابعي الحصاد فقط
دعونا نذكر ما هو الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل الاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل هي
جمعيه نقبيه منظمه نقابيه وليس بحزب سياسي
وانما السيد الطبوبي والمكتب التنفيذي
الحالي يريد ان يذهب به الى الحزب السياسي
وتدخل في السياسه اليوم لم نرى مطلبا
واحدا نقابيا او اجتماعيا اليوم راينا
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل يتحدث
السياسه ويتكلم في السياسه وهو مهامه
الاصليه هو ولكن هذا الاتحاد عفوا سيدي
الهمامي يعني انت الان تتجاهل دور الاتحاد
التاريخي
ودوره ايضا في في الماضي القريب عندما كان
احد الاطراف الثلاثه الذين
تمكنوا من ايصال البلاد الى البر الامان
ومن توافق اجراء توافق سياسي في البلاد
وبالتالي لم يكن هذا الصوت معترضا على ما
يقوم به الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
شكرا لك
فتح المجال فقط بسيط لانه سؤال كان قاسم
على جزئين الجزء الاول هو ان الاتحاد
جانبه التاريخي جانبه التاريخي هو جانب
عمالي نقابيه الدفاع العمال والنقابيين
وبالنسبه للجانب السياسي ما هو في العشريه
السوداء نحن مع تطبيق القانون والقانون
يقول ان النقابه ليس بحزب سياسي
ومشاركته في الحوار الذي اوصل البلاد
التونسيه نجح في بعض وكذا وفشل في الكثير
واذكر الساده المشاهدين وتذكر الشعب
التونسي يعني
قرطاج واحد التي انتجت لنا الحبيب الصيد
الرئيس الحكومه الذي خرج مهزوما ومعزوما
واذكر الكرت الذي انتج لدى يوسف الشاهد
الذي كان الاتحاد جزء في ذلك وكان الاتحاد
يقول على حكومه يوسف الشاهد هي افشل حكومه
وضعتها البلاد التونسيه دعني اذكر
حتى لا ندخل كثيرا في التفاصيل التاريخيه
انت يعني ركزت على نقطه اساسيه ما داخل ما
دخل الاتحاد التونسي للشغل بالعمل السياسي
طيب
سؤالي مطروح هذا الى سيد طارق السعيدي
يعني لم تكن هناك مطالب كان هناك فقط رفض
كم الافواه والتضييق على الحريات كما
تابعنا في خطاب الطبوب طيب ما علاقه
الاتحاد التونسي بالقضايا السياسيه حتى
يصبح كحزب سياسي هذا ما قله ضيفنا الاخر
نعم مساء الخير تحيه لك ولضيفك المشاهدين
اولا يبدو ان الضيف لم يستمع الى كلمه
رفيق الامين العام نور الدين الطبوبي على
اعتبار انه اخرج عده مراسلات ابعثها
الاتحاد لعام التونسي للشغل داعيا الحكومه
للتفاوض حول عده ملفات عالقه وحول اتفاقات
انضطها هذه الحكومه مش حكومات اقساط مع
الاتحاد والحكومه لم تحرك ساكنا وتجاهلت
المراسلات وهي اربع مراسلات متعلقه بتطبيق
اتفاق سته فيفري وبتطبيق ايضا اتفاق زياده
في الاجور في القطاع العام الذي يبدو ان
الحكومه تراجعت عليه هذا جزء كبير من خطاب
الرفيق من العام كان متنحورا حول هذه
المساله حول رفض الحوار وحول المطالب
الاجتماعيه للعمال وحول الوضع التنموي في
البلاد بشكل عام بطبيعه الحال لابد ايضا
من اشاره الى نقطه مهمه وهي ضروره التمييز
ما بين المفاهيم يبدو ان هناك خلط بما فيه
لدى الضيف
فيما بين مفهوم العمل الحزبي والعمل
السياسي
فالعمل السياسي هو الذي يستهدف السياسات
العامه والاتحاد معني باستهداف سياسات
العامه وبمحاوله فرض
توجه وطني جامع يوحد يعني القوى الوطنيه
من اجل بديل تنموي يخدم مصلحه التونسيين
هذا دوره ولكنه لا يرمو مطلقا الى السلطه
ولا يصارع من اجلها اما بالنسبه الدوره
الوطني التاريخي للاتحاد العام التونسي
شغل عندما يقود فرحات حشاد المعارضه
والمقاومه الوطنيه ضد المستعمر ويستشهد
فاهلا بالاتحاد عندما يدفع احمد
اسمح لي اسمح لي حتى نستغل الوقت ساعود
الى السيد الامامي هل افهم من كلامي سيد
الهمامي ان الرئيس سعيد يتعاطى بلا مبالاه
مع هذا مع هذا الحراك ومع كل من يعارضه
على اعتبار ان هذا ليس شغلهم وليس عليهم
ان يشتغلوا بالسياسه باختصار ارجوك
اختصار شديد صديقي العزيز شكرا لك شديد
ليس التعامل بالمبالاه الرئيس سعيد هو
مبالي بكل التفاصيل التي
تحرمنا الشعب التونسي اليوم رايناه
اتحاد العام التونسي للشغل لانه حشر نفسه
في صراع وحرب بالوكاله ضد المطالب الشعبيه
التونسيه اليوم راينا اعدادا ضعيفه جدا في
داخل ابو حمدي عليه وادعو السيد نور الدين
طوبي تعديل موقفه والتوجه نحو العمل
للنقابي اذكر ماذا قاله في الافتتاحي
كلمته السيد اليوم قال وجه تحيه للمناضلين
الذين في السجن استغربوا كيف السيد نور
الدين طبيب يدافع على حبيب اللوز وكمال
لطيف
التركي السيد السعيدي اذا اذا يعني الشارع
لم يقل كلمته الى جانب الاتحاد كما يقول
السيد الهمامي وبالتالي
الاعداد كانت ضئيله ويبتعد الاتحاد عن
الحس الشعبي اذا صح التعبير ما رايك
انا في اعتقادي انه حظر المظاهرات
والمسيرات اللي دعاه الاتحاد تجمعات في ال
24 ولايه اكثر بكثير من اللي شارك في
الانتخابات ومن العجب بالعجاب انه نتحدث
عن الشعب وقت للشعب شرك بنسبه 11% فقط في
انتخابات والحال ان المفترض انتخابات تكون
جماهيريه فدعى الشعب يرتاح لان الشعب يعرف
اقصد السيد يعني الضيف دعى الشعب يرتاح لا
ترهقه بالتكلم باسمه وانتم لا تمثلوا من
يمثله الان وهنا هو الرئيس قيس سعيد
بانتخابات ديمقراطيه فاز بها وهذا امر
صحيح ولكن خلاف ذلك لا يجب لا نتحدث باسم
الشعب الاتحاد العام التونسيه شغل جمع
الالاف اليوم
وهو في اطار مسار التعبوي تام الفيديوهات
والصور تؤكد العمق الشعبي لهذه
وتنفي ادعاءات المئات او العشرات ثم ان
الاتحاد عندما ياخذ هذه المعركه من اجل
التنميه فانه يخوض من اجل وحده الوطن ومن
اجل وحده الجهد في مقاومه الصقر وضعف
التنميه وليس في اطار استعراض العضلات ولا
يريد بذلك اثبات قوه ضد احد شكرا لك طارق
الصعيدي الصحفي بجريده الشعب التابعه
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وشكرا لاحمد
الهمامي المتعدث باسم تحالف احرار من تونس
ونبقى في تونس التي غادرها اكثر من
ثلاثمائه من طالب اللجوء ينتمون الى دول
افريقيه بينها غينيا ومالي وكوت ديفوار
الى بلدانهم خوفا من موجه عنف بعد تصريح
للرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مثيرا للجدل بشان
المهاجرين وقال دبلوماسي مليء طائره تقل
133 مواطنا ماليا غادرت تونس السب كما
اعلن سفير كوت ديفوار في تونس ان طائره
اخرى تحمل 145 من مواطني اقلعت من تونس في
اليوم ذاته وكان سعيد قد طلب المسؤولين
باتخاذ اجراءات عاجله للتصدي للهجره غير
النظاميه قائلا ان هناك مؤامره اجراميه
جاريه لتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في
تونس من جانب اكدت الخارجيه التونسيه في
وقت سابق ان السلطات التونسيه لم ترى حل
اي او لم ترح ل اي مواطن اجنبي بصفه قصريه
من بين الجاليات الموجوده في تونس
وقال محمد بن غونا المكلف بالعلاقات
الخارجيه في جمعيه الطلبه والمتدربين
الجابونيين في تونس انهم يعيشون اوضاعا
مقلقه واضاف بانجون في مقابله مع الجزيره
في نشره سابقه ان الاوضاع في تونس كانت
افضل في الماضي وان كثيرا من الطلاب لم
يعودوا يستطيعون الالتحاق بفصولهم وباتوا
يتابعون دراستهم عن بعد
تصعب ومعقد عشنا اوقات جيده في السابق لكن
الان هناك الكثير من الخوف والقلق والترقب
لما ستؤول اليه الاوضاع في تونس بعد
تصريحات رئيس الجمهوريه السيد قيس سعيد
التي يمكن وصفها بالعنصريه وتمثل جزءا من
المجتمع التونسي لكنها بالتاكيد لا تمثل
كل تونس
[موسيقى]
رئيس حكومه الوحدات الوطنيه عبد الحميد
دبيبه على ان اي قاعدات دستوريه يجب ان
تطرح للاستفتاء الشعبي كما اكد رفضه عوده
الحكم العسكري مجددا الى البلاد ياتي ذلك
بعد يومين من موافقه المجلس الاعلى للدوله
في ليبيا على تعديل دستوري كان قد اقره
مجلس النواب بالتشاور معه وهو الامر الذي
يمهد لاجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه
متى تنتخب دون ليبيا وذلك سجلات سياسيه
وقانونيه لابد للامر من اليه وقاعده
دستوريه ذاك عينهما تراه حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه لكنها تريد اخضاع الامر
اولا للاستفتاء الشعبي
ما عندناش
وصوتوا عليه بنعم ولا لا
ونقول له كلنا لابد نصوت فيه ونقولوا يا
هذا الدستور يصلح فينا مش نكيفوني اجل عبد
الحميد والله اجل عمار والله
هذا يصلح لليبيا ويصلح لي 100 سنه كلامه
يسير عكس اتجاه المجلس الاعلى للدوله
بموافقته الخامسه على تعديل للاعلان
الدستوري يمهد لاجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه
التعديل الذي اقره مجلس النواب بالتشاور
مع مجلس الدوله حدد شكل السلطه التشريعيه
لكنه ترك شروط الترشح للرئاسه دون حسم اذ
لم يعالج الخلافه الجوهري حول ترشح
العسكريين ومزدوجي الجنسيه كخليفه حفتر
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ثم ان التعديل لا يمكن ان يكون بديلا
لقاعده دستوريه ناظمه للانتخابات
لذلك وغيره بدا كان الممثل الخاص للامين
العام للامم المتحده في ليبيا قد يئس من
جدوى عمل المؤسسات الليبيه التي حكم عليها
بالفشل فعبد الله بتيلي يتجه لانشاء اليه
بديله تتمثل في لجنه تسيير رفيعه المستوى
للانتخابات في ليبيا وحدد للجنه مهمه
اعتماد اطار قانوني وجدول زمني ملزم
لاجراء الانتخابات خلال العام الحالي
هو اذا سحب للبساط من تحت اقدام مجلسي
النواب والدوله بدعم امريكي وغربي اصحاب
هذا الراي سيجدون سندا في دعوه واشنطن
الفرقاء الليبيين الى الاصطفاف وراء
مبادره الموفد الاممي لكن يبدو ان مصارعه
مجلس الدوله للمصادقه على التعديل الثالث
عشر للاعلان الدستوري بمن حضر اعاد كما
يبدو خلط الاوراق
يجادل اعضاء في مجلس الدوله بعدم قانونيه
الجلسه لعدم توفر النصاب وينبه غيرهم الى
ان مجلس النواب نشر التعديل في الجريده
الرسميه قبل مصادقه مجلس الدوله عليه
بينما تسعى الامم المتحده لاستعاده زمام
المبادره تسعى قياده المجلسين الليبيين
كما يبدو للاحتفاظ باداره العمليه
السياسيه وفي اثناء ذلك يمضي الوقت دون ان
يصل البلد المنقسم سياسيا والمنهك
اقتصاديا وامنيا الى اخر محطات مراحده
الانتقاليه
الازمه السياسيه الليبيه تراوح مكانها في
ظل عدم التوافق على نقاط خلافيه ابرز هذه
النقاط ترشح مزدوجي الجنسيه تفاصيل الخلاف
نستعرضها في التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
تعود جذور الازمه السياسيه الليبيه الى
حقبه الانقسام الحادي في مراحل والذي تطور
الى اقتتال في مراحل اخرى اخر فصول الخلاف
السياسيه وتفسير القاعده الدستوريه وهو ما
يهدد تنظيم انتخابات البرلمانيه ورئاسيه
ترى انتظارها نقطه الخلاف الرئيسيه والتي
عطلت التوافق على القاعده الدستوريه كانت
احقيه ترشح مزدوج الجنسيه فهذه المساله
يصر عليها رئيس مجلس النواب عقيل صالح
ويرفضها بشده رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشري والمعني بها بشكل اكبر اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر لم تفلح اجتماعات
لجان تم تشكيلها لحسم المساله ولا لقاءات
مباشره برعايه اطراف اقليميه جمعت صالح
والمشري في احداث اي اختراق في جدار
المواقف الصلبه الى ان اطلق المبعوث
الامامي عبد الله بتلي في 27 من فبراير
شباط الماضي مبادره جديده لاجراء
الانتخابات خلال العام الجاري مبادره
باتيلي تقضي بانشاء تتولى اعتماد اطار
قانوني وجدول زمني ملزم لاجراء الانتخابات
هذا العام الى جانب التوافق على شروط منها
تامين الانتخابات واعتماد ميثاق شرف
للمرشحين خطه مبعوث الامي حركت مياه
السياسه الراكده في ليبيا اياما بعد اعلان
خطته في مجلس الامن صوت مجلس الدوله في
جلسه رافقها الجدل على اقرار التعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر الذي سبق واقره مجلس
النواب في السابع من فبراير شباط ويقضي
التعديل بانتخاب رئيس دوله بشكل مباشر
وبرلمان بمجلسين واحد للنواب في بنغازي
واخر للشيوخ في طرابلس لكن نقطه الخلاف
الرئيسيه في شروط الترشيح تم ترحيلها الى
لهجه سيتم تشكيلها لاحقا تضم سته اعضاء
يرشح مجلس النواب وسته اخرين يرشحوا مجلس
الدوله ما يعني استمرار الجدل نفسه لكن في
لجنه فرعيه في غياب اي مؤشر على رغبه
الاطراف في تغيير مواقفها السابقه ومن
بعيد يراقب رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد الدبيبه المشهد ويشترط خضوع
التعديلات الدستوريه للاستفتاء الشعبي
لحصوله على الشرعيه ويتفق مع المشري في
مساله رفضه عوده العسكريين الى الحكم
معنى من طرابلس المحلله السياسيه محمد
محفوظ مرحبا بك سيد محمد
بعد مبادره عبد الله باتيلي والتعديل
الدستوري الثالث بالاتفاق بين مجلس نواب
والمجلس الاعلى للدوله اين يندرج كلام عبد
الله عبد الحميد دبيبه
مساء الخير استاذ حسن لك ولمشاهدي الجزيره
الكرام دون شك اتضح اليوم ان سبب ربما سبب
عدم وجود بيان يرحب باحاطه بتيلي ويرحب
بالمخرجات التي انتجتها هذه الاحاطه من
قبل حكومه الوحده الوطنيه بات اليوم واضحا
ان الحكومه ورئيسه عبد الحميد بيبه ليس
راضيا بشكل او اخر على هذه الاحاطه وعلى
المسار الذي قد تقوده البعثه نحو
الانتخابات يعني اتضح اليوم القول الذي
كنا دائما نقوله ان جميع السلطه من هم
موجودين عفوا من هم موجودين في السلطه
بدءا من الحكومه الى مجلس النواب مجلس
الاعلى للدوله الرئاسي ليسوا اصحاب مصلحه
في اجراء الانتخابات باختلاف الاسباب
وباختلاف التوجهات مساله حتى المسار الذي
يخوض فيه اليوم المجلس الاعلى للدوله
ومجلس النواب فيما يتعلق بالتعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر اعتقد بالنسبه لدبي
هو مسار اكثر امانا من مسار البعث الامميه
لانه كما يعلم الجميع انه مجلس النواب
والدوله من الصعب جدا او او اعتقد انه من
المستحيل ان يتفقا على شروط الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه حتى الحديث الذي يعني
يجري الايام الماضيه فيما يتعلق بحدود
توافق اعتقد انه توافق صوري سيصل الى حاله
تصادم فور ان يكون هناك نقاش جدي وعميق
حول مساله شروط الترشح وبالتالي بالنسبه
لعبد الحميد اعتقد ان مسار مجلس النواب
والدوله يضمن له البقاء لان هذا المسار
سيعيش حاله من السداد بينما مسار البعثه
التي التي يقول الذي يقود بتيري مسار
الصارم من حيث الزمن وحتى من حيث
اعتقد في حاله نجاح نعم
يصعب المهمه من حيث انه اولا الاتفاق على
القاعده الدستوريه وهذا متعذر ثم طرحها
على استفتاء شعبي ايضا يصبح الامر قد يكون
متعذرا بشكل اكبر في ظل هذه الظروف لكن
السؤال هل بامكان عبد الحميد الدبيبه
بالتكافل والتضامن مع المجلسين ان يعطلان
مبادره الامميه
استاذ حسن انا ارى اليوم في حاله
اجماع او حاله شبه توافق بين من هم
موجودين في السلطه على مساله البقاء
وبالتالي هناك تقارير تتحدث على سبيل
المثال ان هناك تواصلات تجريبين حكومه
الدبيبه وحكومه بشارى الموجوده في سر على
مساله ضمان الحاله الموجوده حاليا وعدم
دعم اي مسارات امميه حتى تستمر هذه الحاله
لانه حكومه بشاره تسيل لها ميزانيات حكومه
دبيبه سيئه ميزانيات وبالتالي الحديث عن
مسار امم جديد هو يعني انه ستنتهي هاتين
الحكومتين وستذهب البلاد نحو حكومه اخرى
هذا هذا هذه التقارير اعتقد ان في تقدير
يمكن تصديقها اليوم لا يمكن ان اعتقد انه
عبد الحميد بيبقى قد يلجا للمجلسين لانه
ايضا هناك حاله تنافر كبيره يعيش الذبيبه
مع المشري ومع عقيله هناك حاله عداء معلنه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد في وقت سابق كان
المشري وعقيله يسعيان بشكل حثيت وبشكل قوي
للدخول في مفاوضات ظاهرها اخراج القاعده
الدستوريه حتى يكون هناك ارضاء للمجتمع
الدولي وكذلك للاطياف المحليه ولكن باطلها
هو التوافق على حكومه جديده حتى يكون هناك
تقاسم سلطه جديد اليوم المعطيات تتغير
اليوم معطيات الامم المتحده اصبحت اكثر
فاعليه اعتقد مثل ما ذكرت في بدايه حديث
اليوم كل من هم موجودين لا تخدمهم هذه
الخارطه الامميه حتى ترحيب المجلس الرئاسي
الذي اعتقده ترحيبا قد يامل به المجلس
الرئاسي ليلعب دورا في هذه المبادره
الامميه لان هناك تقارير تؤكد ان المبعوث
والدول الثلاثيه الدائمه فرنسا الولايات
المتحده بريطانيا قد يلجاون للماجستيراسي
لتنفيذ بعد بنود بعض بنود هذه الخطه التي
قالها بتيري في الاحاطه لكن بشكل عام ايضا
المجلس الرئاسي ليس متحمسا على لسان
مستشار السياسي يقول انه لا يمكن ان يبتعد
عن اي ادوار حقيقيه لمجلس نواب والدوله
محمد محفوظ المحلل السياسي من طرابلس شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
قال قائد العمليات الخاصه في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه فيكتور
هورينكو ان قوتي بلاده في ضخمه تعمل في
ظروف شديده الصعوبه وتبذو القصارى جهدها
لوقتها جامعه العدو حسب قوله واختها فقد
خورنكو وحداته المشاركه في القتال في
مدينه
واشار من هناك الى اهميه التواصل والتفاعل
بين جميع الوحدات التي تشكل هيكل القوات
الاوكرانيه الخاصه
في المقابل تفقد وزير دفاع روسيا قوه
الشرق في محور جنوب دونيتس وشدد على اهميه
ضمان تقديم الدعم الشامل لقوه هذه الوحده
وتنظيم عمل وحدات الدعم ولم تشهر وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه الى توقيت هذه الزياره
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره في ولايه هاتايا
الجنوبيه تركيا بان سفينتين محملتين
بمساعدات قطريه وسلطان ميناء اسكندرون
واعلمتنهما نحو 400 منزل جاهز من اصل عشره
الاف عدد بها قطر ومن المقرر ان توزع
المساعدات على الولايات المتضرره من
الزلزال في تركيا كما يرسل جزء منها الى
المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
السفينه الاولى التي وصلت الى ميناء
اسكندرون
من الدوحه تحمل اول دفعه من المساعدات
القطريه البيوت المسبقه صنع القطريه التي
ستقدم الى متضررين في تركيا والشمال
السوري هذه السفينه حوت اكثر من
ثلاثه مئه بيت مسبق الصنع كما تشاهدون
بهذا الشكل على ان تصل خمس سفن سفن اخرى
ليصل مجموع السفن التي تصل كدفعه اولى
سبعه سفن ثم اربعه عشر سفينه خلال الايام
المقبله عدد الوحدات السكنيه التي ستصل في
هذه المرحله
4200 وحده على ان يصل مجموع الوحدات
السكنيه التي ستقدمها دوله قطر الى تركيا
10 الاف وحده سكنيه ستوزع مكتمل المساعدات
القطري تسلم من قبل المساعدات القطريه الى
اداره الكوارث التركيه وايضا الهلال
الاحمر ليتم توسيعها على المتضررين في
الولايات التركيه نسيجه الزلزال اضافه الى
جزء سيخصص للمتضررين في الشمال السوري عمر
الحاجه الجزيره من ميناء اسكندرون في
ولايتها طاي
[موسيقى]
التدريبات العسكريه الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه المسماه الدرع لتعزيز القدرات
البلدين الدفاعيه تثير حفيظه كوريا
الشماليه
تبدا المناورات في الثالث عشر من هذا
الشهر وتستمر عشره ايام بلا انقطاع وقال
البلدان ان مناوراتهما تجري في اطار
سيناريوهات واقعيه تحاكي التهديدات
النوويه التي تمثلها كوريا الشماليه كان
الجيش الامريكي والجيش الكوري الجنوبي قد
اجريا مناورات جويه مشتركه اشاره الماضي
قالت سول انها سمحت باظهار القدره على
النشر الفوري لوسائل الردع الامريكيه
الموسعه في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
جاء ذلك عقب اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخا
عابرا للقارات سقط في مياه اليابان وقالت
بيونغيانغ ان تجربته تهدف الى تعزيز
قدرتها الهجوميه النوويه القاتله
وشملت التدريبات الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه استخدام قاذفه امريكيه من طراز
بي 1 ومقاتلات الشبح اف 35 ومقاتلات اف 15
واف سته عشر
الامريكي النفاثه
كوريا الشماليه انتقدت تدريبات درع الحريه
المرتقبه ووصفتها مع غيرها من التدريبات
بانها استعدادات لشن حرب عدوانيه عليها
وحذرت من ان سولوا واشنطن ستواجهان ردود
فعل قويه وغير مسبوقه وقالت
ان اطلاقها الشهر الماضي صاروخا باليسيا
عاذرا للقارات من طراز هو سونج 15 يندرج
في اطار تدريبات لردع الخصوم وقد تصاعدت
حده التوتر في شبه الجزيره الكوريه منذ
اعلان الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جون اون
رسميا في سبتمبر الماضي سياسه تجعل من
الوضعيه النوويه لبلاده امرا لا رجعت فيه
واجرت عددا قياسيا من التجارب على اسلحتها
بما في ذلك الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات
[موسيقى]
معنا من اوكسفورد
جوليو بولينزي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
المختص بشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه اوكسفورد
مرحبا بك سيد جوليو
يعني ان تقول كوريا الشماليه ان هذه
التدريبات الامريكيه الكوريه الجنوبيه
تهدف الى شن حرب عليها او غزو كوريا
الشماليه ما مدى واقعيه هذا التخوف
الذي تبديه كوريا الشماليه ازاءه تلك
التدريبات
صحيح انه كان هنالك
زياده في التدريبات
العسكريه وقرب ايضا بالقرب من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه لان الاداره الامريكيه ترغب بدء
انخراطي
بدفع وضغط على كوريا الشماليه من اجل ان
تدخل كوريا الشماليه في اتفاق من اجل
السيطره على برنامجها النوويه كان وهذا
يهدف الى
تحجيمي كوريا الشماليه بالتالي
نشهده الان
هو موقف متوتر في نتيجه هذه
بسبب التنافس بين الصين
والولايات المتحده
كوريا الجنوبيه تريد ان تطمئن حول مساله
الرد النوويه في المنطقه والولايات
المتحده تحتاج ان توفر وتستثمر هذا الامر
بالتالي ان ايضا يكون هنالك تنظيم لعمليه
الفعل ورد الفعل ياتي هذا عن طريق
التدريباتي العسكريه المتزايده لكن من
الواضح ان العناصر تهدف كل ما يحدث يهدف
الى الردع والتصميم الحلفاء بدلا من مساله
لكن في المقابل يعني
يجب النظر في المقابل الى كوريا الشماليه
هل تتوقع ان يكون لديها رد فعل ازاء هذه
التدريبات
ان كوريا الشماليه من الواضح ان قد
قفزت واستغلت هذه المنافق المناسبه من اجل
استعراض قدراتها الصاروخيه النوويه قد
نشهد قريبا ربما
عمليه اطلاق صواريخ نوويه جديده بالتالي
كوريا الشماليه تريد ان تظهر انها
تمتلك الصواريخ النوويه هي اطلقت اطلق
اكبر عدد من 2022 مره اخرى الغرض من ذلك
سيكون هو الردع لكن علينا ان نضمن ان
الازمات يتم
ادارتها بدون زياده في توتر
الموقفورد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص
بشؤون الاسيويه بجامعه اوكسفورد شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
غادروا بلادهم سعيا لحياه افضل ثم عادوا
اليها بحثا عن الامان هكذا هو حال نحو 300
مهاجر من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء حطت بهم
طائرتان من مالي وكوت ديفوار عائدين من
تونس كانت رحله اولى اعدت حول 50 غينيا
الى بلدهم الاربعاء من بين المهاجرين
العائدين عشرات الطلاب المنحدرين من
عائلات ثريه والذين التحقوا بجامعات خاصه
مرموقه او الحاصلين على منح دراسيه من
الدوله
من حال الى حال تتغير اوضاع الناس وخططهم
للمستقبل لفعل تطورات لا حيله لهم فيها
وتتركهم امام خيار صعب اما البقاء في بلاد
الغير بلادهم ومواجهه مناخ عام يقول عدد
منهم انهم اصبح انه اصبح يهدد حياتهم او
ترك اعمالهم ودراساتهم والعوده لديارهم
نشتانا للدفء والامان
دمتم في امان والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]